Realiza una tabla y resuelve.
Y dice así, un biólogo realiza una investigación
sobre el impacto de tres diferentes bebidas
azucaradas a base de agua para la habilidad
de las abejas de producir miel.
Él toma dos litros de la bebida A, la cual
contiene 40% de azúcar...
y como estoy viendo que vamos a utilizar muchos
datos, déjame ir creando la tabla...
Entonces en mi primera columna voy a poner
la cantidad de bebida, en mi segunda columna
el porcentaje de azúcar que tiene esta bebida y por último y  esto creo que va a ser muy importante,
voy a poner aquí la cantidad azúcar...
no, no, no... la cantidad de azúcar....
la cantidad de azúcar que vamos a obtener
de cada una de estas bebidas.
Y fíjate bien, empezamos con dos litros de
la bebida A, la cual contiene 40% de azúcar,
entonces vamos a escribirlo de una vez, la bebida...
la bebida A, de la bebida A vamos a tomar 2 litros...
2 litros...
y de estos 2 litros de la bebida A,
el 40% es azúcar, el 40% de estos
2 litros es azúcar y entonces
si yo lo que quiero saber es la cantidad de azúcar que hay en estos dos litros,
hay que multiplicar 2 litros por el 40%, es decir por el 0.4 lo cual me da 0.8, 0.8 litros son de azúcar.
Muy bien, esto en la bebida A, 0.8 litros
son de azúcar, mientras que 1.2 litros son
de agua, es por eso que tenemos una
bebida azucarada al 40%.
Ahora, a esto le vamos a agregar 1.2 litros
de la bebida B,
entonces la bebida B son 1.2 litros...
1.2 litros...
Y bueno, no nos dice que porcentaje tenemos
de azúcar, pero nos dice que vamos a obtener
una nueva solución llamada bebida C, entonces
aquí vamos a ponerle, la suma de estas dos
nos va a dar la bebida C, de la cual date
cuenta que vamos a obtener 3.2 litros,
es decir, la suma de la bebida A más la bebida
B y esta bebida C, tiene un 25% de azúcar,
entonces, el porcentaje de azúcar que tenemos
es un 25% y pues también podemos obtener
de aquí cual es la cantidad de azúcar que
tenemos de estos 3.2 litros,
porque es 3.2 por el 25%, es decir, 3.2 por .25,
lo cual es 0.8 litros.
Es muy fácil, lo único que estoy haciendo es tomándome 1/4 de 3.2 litros, es decir, el 25%.
Y nos preguntan,
¿cuál es el porcentaje de azúcar en la bebida B?
Así que vamos a llamar a este porcentaje
de azúcar "x", el porcentaje de azúcar de
la bebida B es "x" y vamos a pensar que ya está en decimal, para no meternos en más problemas.
Por lo tanto, si nosotros queremos saber la
cantidad de azúcar que tiene la bebida B,
pues habría que multiplicar 1.2 por "x", porque "x" ya lo estamos viendo en su forma decimal,
"1.2x" es la cantidad de azúcar
que tenemos en la bebida B.
Ahora date cuenta de los siguiente, la suma
de la cantidad de azúcar de la bebida A más
la suma de la cantidad de azúcar de la bebida
B, tiene que ser igual a la cantidad de azúcar
que tiene la bebida C, pero como la cantidad de azúcar
de la bebida A y de la bebida C es la misma,
esto significa que "x" es igual a 0.
Y eso nos da pie a la siguiente ecuación,
0.8 litros más "1.2x" litros
es igual a 0.8 litros de azúcar, pero si yo resto de aquí,
0.8 de ambos lados,
me queda que "1.2x" es igual a 0 o que "x" es igual a 0, es decir, para obtener la bebida C
que tenga 0.8 litros de azúcar, tenemos que agregarle a la bebida A, una bebida B que sea agua pura...
¡Wow, esto está genial!
Es decir, que no contenga azúcar, que tenga
el 0% de azúcar.